250 mph— that's the speed of the
fastest cars in the world. It's also
the speed at which messages travel from
our brain to the rest of the body,
telling our legs to walk or our hand to
grab a drink when we're thirsty. That's
incredibly fast and it's necessary in
order to allow us to interact with and
respond to the world around us. These
messages travel in the form of
electricity down specific paths made up
of long chains of cells called neurons.
The neuron is a very unusual type of
cell in the body because it has very
long extensions. The neuron has a cell
body, which contains a nucleus,
surrounded by cell membrane extensions,
or processes called dendrites, which
act like antennae to receive signals
from other neurons. The neuron then
extends a single, very long process
called an axon that ends in the axon
terminal. Some axons can be very long,
one meter in the case of some neurons
in your leg. The electrical signal
travels from the cell body, down the
axon, to the terminal. The terminal is
then triggered to release a chemical
signal that travels from that neuron to
another one. This starts an electrical
current in that second neuron. And so
electrical signals pass from one neuron
to another to another, allowing a
thought that starts in your brain to
travel to a muscle in your foot.
Since axons are the long distance wires
in this communication circuit, fast
transmission of the electrical signal
down the axon is crucial for us to
chase down a fly away umbrella or jump
out of the way of a falling rock. To
enable this rapid transport of a
message along the axon, our bodies rely
on myelin.
Although observed as part of the
nervous system as early as 1717, myelin
was first named as such by Rudolf
Virchow, a German physician, writer and
politician, in 1854. Scientists
theorized a few years later that myelin
was providing the axon with insulation,
which as in a wire, allowed the
electrical signal to move fast with
minimal signal loss as it traveled down
the neuron. This idea proved to be
correct.
Now we know much more about myelin. It
is a fatty substance that covers the
axon in long sections. The fatty myelin
is actually long extensions of cell
membranes made by supporting cells
called glia that wrap around the axons
in concentric circles. In the central
nervous system, meaning the brain and
spinal cord, the glial cells that wrap
their membranes around axons are called
oligodendrocytes.
And in the peripheral nervous system,
in the nerves that travel throughout
the body, they are called Schwann cells.
The myelin wrapping is separated by
very short, unmyelinated gaps that were
spotted by French physician,
Louis-Antoine Ranvier. They were then
named after him as the nodes of
Ranvier. The electrical signal jumps
between these nodes, traveling down the
neuron. Without the nodes, transport
would be at least 15 times slower, not
enough for us vertebrate humans.
However, some animals, such as the
squid and octopus have developed
creative ways to enable fast message
transport without using myelin. These
creatures have axons with a much larger
diameter, which reduces the resistance
the signal experiences in a thinner
axon, allowing the signal to still move
quickly through the animal's body and
allow them to escape from predators.
In humans, if the nerve cells become
demyelinated, the transmission of the
electrical message can be slowed from
the normal 250 mph to 100 mph. Multiple
sclerosis, or MS, is a disease caused
by loss of myelin. The oligodendrocytes
that form the myelin are lost. In MS,
message transport and delivery are
slower in the spinal cord, brain and
eyes. Patients develop symptoms such as
fatigue and trouble with vision, and in
the long run, can suffer brain damage.
While there is no cure yet for multiple
sclerosis, many scientists around the
world are working to try and understand
the underlying cause of MS and other
disorders involving myelin. Treatments
that preserve or replace the myelin
producing cells could transform the
lives of the millions of people
currently living with MS in the United
States.